hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about white tongue
okay this is really an overgrowth of
Candida the condition is called
candidiasis and basically Candida
normally is a friendly thing on your
body you have 20 different strains of
Candida but this yeast like structure
this microbe can turn into a fungus if
you basically take antibiotics or
steroids or birth control pills or
insulin so normally in the body you have
four hundred at least four hundred
different types of species of friendly
bacteria from the yeast friendly mold
friendly fungus and then when you kill
off the good microbes some of these bad
guys can start over taking over and so
what most people do they think that they
should avoid fermented foods because
there's lactic acid or there's some
fermentation there might be some yeast
and they think that if I consume the
friendly yeast it's going to turn into
baddies but really to correct the
situation you need to build up your
friendly flora your friendly microbes
your friendly yeast and so that would be
in some of these fermented vegetables
like you have like sauerkraut kimchi
heathyr is a fermented product from milk
apple cider vinegar these are all very
very essential to eventually get rid of
this stuff now what happens when you
have an imbalance of it's called flora
in your digestive tract if you add too
much of this it can create a little bit
of a reaction and that's when people
think that that's a bad thing so they
avoid all of it but what you want to do
is you want to start a very very small
and work up to it if you have no you
don't have a lot of good friendly
bacteria and you dump a lot of
probiotics into your system or friendly
east you can stir up an immune reaction
so I always like to go slow so you want
to add these fermented foods slowly and
of course you're going to have to avoid
like just milk in general any milk
products unless it's kefir okay and even
then some people have a problem with the
milk type issues but normally you should
be fine the other thing you want to
avoid is of course
sugar because that's gonna feed this
thing I'm more than anything now I like
to instead of taking just a regular
probiotic there's a thing called
effective microbes and this effective
microbes is a combination of a lot of
friendly yeasts and things that you can
take to start not only building up your
friendly bacteria but building up most
of the other microbes in your system
I'll put a link down below of where you
can get it I am not associated with this
company so I'm not going to tell you
what brand to get but I'll just put some
information to research effective
microbes because I believe that they
work a lot better and these effective
microbes hehe it's almost like you don't
need to refrigerate them they last
forever you take just a small amount and
some water before bed and then they
start growing in your system and to
build back up your good yeast and
bacteria so it can kill this off it
takes a bit of time and you go slow okay
so I'll put a link down there but I just
wanted to mention like things like
scraping the tongue trying to sterilize
your body does not work it's an inside
problem you have to fix the overall
balance of microbes and then eventually
clear this out okay thanks for watching